[Music]
hey guys George Campbell here with
another minute money hack today I'm
hacking an online retailer I use way too
much you guessed it
Amazon Oh looks like I just got another
package I don't even know what this is
that's how much stuff I ordered now if
there's one thing I'm good at its
hacking billion-dollar corporations Jeff
Bezos as in mr. Jeffery Preston Bezos
founder of Amazon net worth of 120
billion dollars USD alright let's get to
the hacks hit the clock prices change
all the time but price tracking sites
like camel camel camel no relation let
you know when the price is right
with subscribe and save get automatic
delivery and save up to 15% plus you can
skip deliveries and cancel anytime
unlike that gym membership where you
have to mail in a handwritten breakup
note tap on today's deals to uncover the
deal of the day lightning deals coupons
and more I don't pay full price for
anything except haircuts gotta stay
fresh stop buying digital books go old
school and create an account with your
local library then download livvie apps
on amazon ebooks and audiobooks for free
plus with digital due dates ebooks are
automatically returned I've had a copy
of are you there God It's Me Margaret
since 1999 if they come after me I'm 7
grand in the hole don't pay for two
accounts with Amazon Prime you can
create an Amazon household account with
one other person you live with they'll
have access to the same free stuff like
two days shipping movies music and mold
and there's your minute money hack
you